[Musique]
la 13e édition du prix s'est lui-même
s'est déroulée ce mercredi 8 mars à la
village département à l'occasion de la
journée de la femme un concours de
créativité destiné aux femmes artistes
amateurs dans la femme l'aurore et le
soir de la vie ferait sens cours le
département souhaitait cet avenir ouvrir
le concours aux collégiens et aux
lycéens qu'on ouvre donc la possibilité
aux jeunes car sens vous devez gmt sans
radio free de célimène sur le poteau
monde est passé le syst à l'exemple de
l'éducation passe par notre jeunesse
et si on veut que l'écho la condition
féminine puisse s'améliorer c'est bien à
travers notre jeunesse qui doit gagner
cette situation sans doute un passereau
grâce à son oeuvre intitulée béatitude
elle représente une femme qui est qui et
qui est belle qui est en paix je suis
très très surprise non plus parce que
je pensais pas remporté ce prix je suis
très ému je suis
je suis très heureuse de la
reconnaissance que ça peut apporter à
mon travail en 2016 anne béguin remporté
la douzième édition décrocher le
précieux l'hymen a été pour elle une
révélation à ma portée la confiance en
moi puis ça justifie tout ce temps je
passe à peindre et ça vous donne envie
de peindre encore je voudrais faire une
exposition
j'ai commencé mon premier tableau de
l'exposition
je cherchais le fil conducteur de
l'exposition des oeuvres des 148
participants est disponible à la villa
du département jusqu'au 24 mars 2010
[Musique]